hey youtubers its charlie thank you so
much everyone that submitted questions
for this week's Korra Q&A so there's one
more episode that's gonna be on Friday
this Friday and then the week after that
will be the last two episodes they'll
air together we also got word on the
book for DVD it's gonna be released in
March
there's only commentaries listed for two
episodes it didn't say which but it's
probably gonna be the finale like the
very final episode of korra ever and
then maybe korra alone just because it
felt like it was so important for the
story of book 4 I'm totally sure I'll be
giving away a couple copies whenever
that comes around but yeah it's gonna be
a little while so let us answer some
questions careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
starting with number 1 Edward asks who
is your favorite beifong I mean it used
to be Toph beifong easy answer Lin is
kind of my favorite but only when she's
with other certain characters right now
one of my favorite fan theories is that
she is really mako's mother I don't
think that's the case but she's kind of
like his surrogate mother Linda's a lot
more fun when she's around most of the
younger characters but just Maiko in
general I feel like they have something
special together I will be real bummed
if he goes to the earth Kingdom with
Prince Wu after book 4 is over and
beifong stays in Republic City I would
hope that they would still stay in touch
Lin seems like she's the kind of person
that really enjoys her peace and quiet
but I think she gets lonely just like
everyone else question 2
super this channel asks what made kuvira
such a monster I would say you know she
started out with good intentions and
then just kind of fell down the slippery
slope to being a tyrant you could say
that a lot of dictators in the history
of the world had good intentions and
then just ended up doing terrible
terrible things sometimes that's because
they get bad advice sometimes that's
because they're completely out of touch
with the people that are trying to help
and then sometimes you find out they
were lying all along and they never
wanted to help you they just wanted
power for themselves based on episode 10
it does seem like kuvira is just out for
power she gave that rousing speech about
taking back earth Kingdom land but she
said that's only the beginning meaning
that she probably plans to conquer the
rest of the world and why would you need
to start calling it the earth empire if
all you wanted to do was help people
there's still a lot of things we don't
know about kuvira so I'm hoping she
gives us some more juicy details about
what's going on inside her head
question 3 the new asks what happened to
Azula this show had four books to answer
the question and we still have no
answer I'm starting to think the
question will become the new what
happened to Zuko's mom yeah that's
totally possible they could just save it
for the comics I mean they explained
what happened to Zuko's mom in the
comics it is funny that they brought
grades allowed back to voice minghua but
they haven't really explained what's
going on with Azula it's possible that
she did the same thing that top did like
she just kind of went off into the
wilderness and wandered off until
confirmed dead just presume that she is
alive out there somewhere and given the
speech the Toph gave about leaving
things to the younger folks I don't
expect to see her in the finale they did
say that they would be bringing her back
in the next comic book the smoke and
shadow comic book obviously that'll be a
young version of Azula so I think
they'll just keep her there in that
space question for jackass what the hell
happened to the Kyoshi warriors have
they become extinct or something no
they're not extinct they mostly just
been in the comics just because we
haven't seen them doesn't mean that
they've gone away they're just way too
many things to explain and Mike and
Bryan only have a limited amount of time
so they're focusing on all the core
characters not so much the last
airbender characters I would just assume
they're still on Kyoshi Island doing
fine
whenever kuvira was first looking at
that big map in the first episode it
would have been really cool if we to
sing Kyoshi Island on the map somewhere
even just a small Easter egg I'm totally
cool with them not explaining a lot of
last airbender stuff just as long as
there's like a subtle turn of phrase or
a small joke like the fish vendor with
the picture of Aang like that was the
best Easter egg ever question 5 Nicky s
hey Charlie do you think the team avatar
will be fighting the forces of kuvira or
just korra so you're saying like a one
on one thing like the last time no I
don't think it's gonna be repeat of that
I think they'll have a moment like that
and then Korra will instead of fighting
her have some other solution but I do
think that before that happens there
will be some fighting like they have
Asami's mix and then they have kuvira's
mix so obviously those are probably
gonna throw down first Asami seems so
happy when she was trying to explain
that plan of hers she's just like look
at my project look how amazing this is
that's why she's gonna go down as one of
my favorite Korra characters and just I
love little things about her like that I
think that they will build some of those
mechs I think the issue was that
president Reiko wanted spirit vine
weapons attached to them and that was
what Korra was arguing about so I don't
think that they're gonna do that
but it is possible you could see a bunch
of flying mix with WMDs
strapped to their backs question six
Betty Sue as what are the new inventions
asami and varrick are working on and how
do you think they'll be used well so
like I explained they're basically
flying mechs
but I think what they're gonna do is
they're gonna build them and then only a
couple of them will get used before a
course stops the fight if you look at
the diagram they can actually fit two
people inside them so I'm guessing one
person flies another person operates the
weapons since very cues that EMP I also
think that there'll be a version of that
too like it won't just be the mechs
they'll be something else as they're
working on and since it is Varrick I do
think that there'll be a twist and he'll
do something kind of shady I would be
disappointed if they just completely
made the character do a 180 and he
became this super nice likable guy who
did everything the right way
I mean it's Varrick so he's supposed to
be kind of a but Julie is the one that
balances him out and now that she's
coming back to Republic City I think
he'll go back to being the way he was
before
maybe appreciate her just a little bit
more though question 7 Jedi Knight asks
could there be a possibility of seeing a
montage of future avatars on the last
episode of Korra no I don't think
they're gonna do that they did actually
post a picture from the sound editing
booth they weren't super clear but this
is gonna be one of the final shots of
Korra I don't think it'll be the last
shot of the series just because I don't
think that they would tease that out if
anything it'll be just the birth of the
next avatar if she does end up dying
really I think what they would want to
do is tie up the big storylines and then
leave on an ending that's ambiguous
enough that it gives you some headspace
to think about what might be happening
with the characters it gives them a
future without necessarily completely
spelling it out in great detail and even
if she doesn't actually reconnect with
her past lives I do think we'll see a
visual reference to them even if it's
not in the way we traditionally see them
question number eight Ceylan asks do you
think that bolin will end up with opal
that's a good question I do think that
they'll try to make it work but Bolin
seems like he wants to be a mover star
and opal seems like she wants to stay
with the airbenders I don't see the two
of them moving to Republic City together
but they do have Airbender Island so I
do think they could make it work I'd be
really surprised that they gave us a
flash-forward and showed us like a Bolin
picture with a bunch of Bolin opal
Draenei
I do think they'll end things on good
terms it seems like they're kind of back
together as of episode 10 so you could
just consider them a couple everybody
makes mistakes I mean the avatar
characters aren't infallible so
it's possible they could break up in the
future after the series is over
hopefully not you know I would like to
see them together question number nine
Momo bear asks why had they left chi up
for the past three episodes just
considering he's a little relationship
with Jinora you think they'd mention him
at least you really like Kai I think
that he's really just with the other
airbenders and they just haven't shown
them because they haven't been critical
to the stories they're telling it's
mostly been about the beifongs more so
than the airbenders but I do think when
we come to the big final conflict at
Republic City all the airbenders will
come back to air temple Island so we'll
see Kai then as far as we know the
airbenders aren't quite as critical to
the stories they were in book three
question number ten
Michelle asks I want to know your
thoughts on two things how do you see
maka playing out in the finale do you
think he'll have a bigger role than just
babysitting Wu also do you think the
core will have our own special moment at
the end of the finale or do you think
there will be more of a collaborative
team effort when beating kuvira
so yeah I mean I think that Korra will
have her moment with career it'll be
like the two of them together again
kinda like when they faced off the first
time to answer your question about mokou
I do feel like they're setting it up for
him to go with Wu and become his advisor
that was why I think he made that
comment you're starting to look like the
kind of person I could go to work for
the bummer about that is that it would
take him away from the rest of team
Korra although to be fair I mean if
Korra is gonna continue living if she
doesn't die in the finale then she'll be
able to travel all over the place just
like Aang did so even if Maiko does go
to the earth Kingdom everybody else
could still visit him and they had that
high-speed magnetic rail now too so it's
a lot quicker to get around thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do it
just remember episode 11 is gonna be
this Friday and then the week after that
on the 19th it'll be episode 12 and 13
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner nito canary you win a copy of the
book 3 DVD just be sure to message me on
my channel for details just because I'll
need some shipping information I will
give away another copy of the DVD in
this Friday's video so just be sure to
subscribe to get that and if you guys
haven't seen already Amazon is having a
sale on Avatar comics you can actually
download them if you have like a Kindle
app so you can actually read them
digitally you don't have to buy the
physical copies it's just a quicker way
to get them but they're super cheap so
lots of huge stuff happening this week
midseason finales for air on the flash
tonight so be sure to check back later
for those right
now you can actually click up here for
your mobile phone err on your tablets
the same as the links over here but
click here for my episode 10 video and
click here for all my other avatar bonus
videos thank you so much watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
in a little while